my name is Jeff Bryant I work for
Wolfram Alpha and I'm giving a talk on
Anatomy plot 3d in a sense this is kind
of an extension of the presentation we
gave last year which was about Anatomy
data keiko here's up setting up here in
the front row she actually kind of
overseas a lot of our Anatomy
initiatives I work on just the mainly
the graphics portion so if you have any
questions about Anatomy she might be
able to answer those questions if you
have questions about the graphics
probably more me so with that we'll get
started here so the origins of anatomy
plot 3d were pretty much started last
year when we came out with anatomy data
Anatomy data has a lot of different
properties for anatomy entities heart
left femur bones muscles you name it but
only one of those was graphics 3d and we
provided that last year in version 10
and allows you to download 3d models in
graphics 3d objects for each of these
Anatomy entities and I think we have
something like forty eight hundred
different 3d models I believe something
on the order of that anyway and that's
where everything started and that's all
fine and dandy you can download these
models you can rotate them you know just
like any other graphics 3d object but
essentially that's the end of it I mean
it's it's a graphics 3d object object
just like any other graphics 3d object
you can do graphics programming on it
but if you don't know the structure
that's in there it's kind of really hard
to get in there and manipulate these
things and do anything you might want to
do to annotate them or highlight certain
substructures anything like that so but
as you can see here the graphics 3d
property returns graphics 3d heads but
it contains metadata and this is
something you may not know by looking at
the model because they're kind of hidden
and embedded in there and here you can
see that I've asked for the graphics 3d
of the left hand and I've said turn all
the annotations in two tool tips and so
as a result see if the tool tips are
working here yeah there you go so you
can see here that it actually highlights
each part with what entity it's made up
of and it's the metadata that's actually
buried inside these models that allows
it to know what they're made of
this is actually very important for the
eventual development of anatomy plot 3d
which allows you to then investigate the
inner structure of some of these things
and just to give you an idea of some of
the metadata that's buried in here is
here for example we did the left thumb I
just did a smaller example and I said
give me all the annotations that are
buried in here and you can see here that
we have a number of annotations for all
the different sub parts that includes
the name of the entity the entity itself
that corresponds to that also source
information so you can see we get our
models from body parts 3d and also from
the unified medical language system they
have a unique identifier the umls
concept ID and so we've incorporated
that in there as well for anybody that
might be familiar with the umls they can
easily align these concepts so that's
the graphics 3d portion now in order to
allow you to explore these models a
little bit more instead of the just
being kind of a dead end we needed a way
to extend the graphics 3d language I you
know graphics 3d language has been
around for a long time follows very
well-behaved rules and so we just wanted
to build on top of that but the problem
is the graphics 3d language does not
know what an Anatomy entity is what we
wanted is something that allowed you to
essentially use the language that
already existed but refer to these
things almost like they were primitives
like a sphere or a cuboid or something
like that and be able to apply the same
styling that you might to those types of
things but graphics 3d is very heavily
tied to the front end and so sphere is
known natively to the front end as
something that can be rendered as that
graphical thing Anatomy entities just
format as a yellow box it's not going to
know that it's supposed to be some kind
of a model and it's certainly not going
to go fetch the model and download it so
we wanted to extend it but we did not
put it within graphics 3d itself so we
came up with anatomy plot 3d so here you
can see an example just a very basic
example anatomy plot 3d of just the left
femur this is essentially when you use a
simple form like this is pretty much
just like asking for left femur and then
say give me the graph
3d property at this level they're almost
identical it's just a magic wrapper that
does that for you but it allows you to
do things that just retrieving the
graphics 3d property wouldn't allow you
to do and once again it follows pretty
much the same rules that the graphics 3d
language does with some editions so
here's a basic example so imagine
replacing each of these entities with a
sphere and you would get a very similar
type behavior so here you can see you
know we've got a red left femur a blue
right femur and then we've even got some
scoping here so we've got a list here
where the hip bone is yellow now we jump
up back out out of that list and we ask
for the sacrum and it falls back to the
blue color that was back here so it
allows you to style these entities just
like they were primitives in the
graphics 3d language but as as before
the head of the result is still graphics
3d so if you wanted to you could still
go in and do whatever graphics 3d
programming you wanted it's just a
convenience thing it's kind of like plot
3d returns a graphics 3d result but it
allows a lot of evaluations and options
and things like that that can allow you
to you know evaluate and get a lot more
power out of it basics of anatomy plot
3d so it is an extension of the graphics
3d language and as such you can combine
regular graphics 3d language primitives
along with these entity references so
here you can see I've combined the left
femur and I've also Justin cuted
included just a regular graphics 3d
cuboid very simple examples not really
all that applied but it does show that
you can mix the two things together and
it also takes the same options as
graphics 3d however we have a lot of
convenience things that have been at it
so here you can see we've got you know
the left hand the right hand and then
we're telling it we want to draw a line
from the left hand to the right hand so
what we've done is we've actually
extended a lot of the graphics 3d
primitives so that they can actually
take entities in their location
arguments so any place you might expect
a graphics 3d language to take like a
sphere you know where do you want to
place the sphere you could put an entity
there if you wanted you would end up
drawing a sphere at the location of the
left hand or the location of the left
femur so that's kind of a convenience
that you can
they kind of mix the two things together
another example here you can see where
I've done skeleton the right hand this
shows you can annotate things so here I
say draw red arrow from this coordinate
to the right fifth metacarpal and then
also label it with some text so I've
mixed once again graphics 3d with some
of the anatomy concepts so this really
is just an extension of the graphics 3d
language now those were very simple
examples just to kind of give you an
idea where we're going with this but it
became very clear for specially some of
the larger structures like the hand or
the left leg or something like that we
have many different tissue types mixed
into one structure we wanted to be able
to dig in and kind of manipulate the
inner structure without having to ask
for the individual things that are added
up and build it up from scratch and in
order to do that we came up with a new
structure or a new language element
called Anatomy form and this really only
has meaning inside of anatomy plot 3d it
does not apply to the graphics 3d
language it only applies to anatomical
entities that are in the argument so
here you can see I've said Anatomy form
edge form thick blue so and then left
femur and I put a cuboid and notice that
it's only applying the edge form thick
blue to the left femur it's not applying
it to the cuboid which is right here so
Anatomy form only applies to the anatomy
elements you could also just use edge
form thick and blue and it would apply
to both but if you use Anatomy form
that's kind of a way to say just do it
for the anatomy stuff but Anatomy form
has some additional forms that are a
little bit more useful and this is the
part that allows you to dig in anatomy
form takes an association and here you
can see I've said give me the left hand
but the preceding Anatomy form says make
the bones blue and make the muscles
green so with very short syntax I've
been able to dig in without having to
query for the individual structures
manually I've just been able to specify
essentially the tissue types which
themselves are entities and just said
coloroll all the muscles blue and all
are all the muscles green and all the
bones blew another a similar example
here we've got the left arm and we want
the long
so up here is a good example of tissue
types we're muscle and bone here we've
dug in and we've actually specified
individual muscles so here long head of
the x left biceps brachii is green and
the short head of the left biceps
brachii is blue so it allows you to dig
in at multiple levels not just a tissue
type level but you can refer to
individual actual entities not just
their kind of parent tissue types so
here's just a little fancier example
should be able to enlarge this I think
a little bit bigger so it's easier to
see so this is kind of an x-ray effect
and so what we've done is we've designed
a custom light source here called
reverse lights where it's essentially
just got a single black ambient light
and then we've got a table of
directional lights it's essentially it's
a ring of lights that we've set up
behind the scene so that allows things
to look back lit kind of so you get kind
of an edge but then everything in the
front kind of is has a black look and
then in addition we've combined that
with Anatomy form and here you can see
we're asking for the left arm but the
preceding Anatomy form right here says
make the left humerus red with the
underscore here indicates everything
else should have this directive which
has a certain specularity certain color
and then it has the lights that we told
it to use so essentially it kind of
gives you this x-ray like effect we're
hoping to improve on this in the future
actually and kind of have some name
directives so you don't have to build
some of these things out there kind of
like themes almost like plot themes but
they're done at the directive level as
opposed to globally for the whole scene
I'll mention a little bit more about
future directions at the end of the talk
we've actually got a couple options that
are to take advantage of these entities
so here for example plot range which is
something that works on all graphics 3d
you can actually specify an auntie for
your plot range so here we've said give
me the left femur the left tibia the
left fibula and the left patella but
make the plot range only the left
patella and then give it some plot range
padding so essentially you said pull in
pretty much all the major bones of the
leg and by default you would see all of
them but now we've said but make the
plot range just the patella and just Pat
it out a little bit so it kinda loud you
to zoom into a particular feature of
interest we've also got an option called
skin style this is more of a convenience
option more than anything else by
default most of these structures will
not pull in the parts of the skin that
correspond to them the skin is kind of
its own separate thing it's not
considered like the skin here is not
part of the left hand by default but you
can by default I'm sorry you can't say
skin style goes to automatic by default
it's none and it will pull in kind of a
transparent the skin that overlays that
particular part for you and if you don't
like the default style you can actually
override it here I've said give me the
right hand and make the skin style
transparent blue a little bit of a side
something that we added in version 10
for the graphics 3d language not just
for anatomy but graphics 3d is clip
planes this is an option you can use for
any graphics 3d that allows you to apply
clipping planes it doesn't actually
modify the underlying polygons is purely
done in the front end and it actually
allows you to cut across entire
structures okay so here you can see an
example of what we supported inversion
sorry I've lost my mouse here there it
is you can see here we've added to clip
planes option to the whole scene and
it's cut through both spheres here red
and a blue sphere but in version 11 we
added the ability to have clip planes be
directives so kind of in the same way
that lighting can be a directive and
apply to only certain elements in the
scene you can do the same thing with
clip planes so here we've got the same
two spheres but in this case the clip
plane only applies to the outer red
sphere this was very useful to us for
anatomy because we wanted to be able to
cut away for example muscle and skin but
still be able to see bones and stuff so
we are really pushed for this feature to
make it into 11 and we're glad that it
did
spitting here so here's some more
applied examples where we used clipping
planes on some anatomy so here you can
see we've done the entire the entire
left upper limb but we've put a clipping
plane and then the skin of the left
upper limb so you can actually see we
can kind of do these cutaways and
reveals and see the structures that are
underneath here's a more complicated
example where we've done it for multiple
structures so here we've done we've cut
the muscles you can see that it's part
of the directive for the muscles there's
a clip plane in there and then similarly
we've got the scan with a different clip
plane and then we've got the bones
something else that you can do is not
just the primitives but also the
geometric transformations so here you
can see we've got to rotate mouse isn't
behaving here there we go so here you
can see down here at the bottom we've
got three different skulls or it's the
same skull in all cases but what we've
done is we've applied a rotation
transform to the mandal and the
mandibular damn dentition and you can
actually modify these and you can see
that I've rotated them around the temple
mandibular joint so I specified this as
the rotation point and I've essentially
just given it three different rotation
angles at 0 10 and 20 degrees and so on
the left you see the jaws closed and it
opens up a little bit at 10 degrees and
then another one at 20 degrees and you
could actually animate this and you
could actually use the manipulate where
the jaw opens and closes these are just
some advanced examples here where you
can see how far you can push it with
some really highly stylized models and
stuff these are actually bitmaps I
didn't leave Dennis models because with
this many polygons and I will mention
that for anatomy data and Anatomy models
these models are not small they are big
so if you're planning to use them keep
that in mind when you're trying to
download them they are not going to come
up just like that these are not just
simple we may in the future to try to
optimize them a little bit but the goal
here was to go for kind of quality and
detail these are not low poly models
with
sures these are high poly models that
are they get their detail from the
number of polygons not from some texture
that's on them so big examples like this
you've got a lot of polygons in here
plus you've got transparency and 3d so
this can take some time to render these
as well so just keep that in mind if
you're going to ask for large structures
and start doing things like rendering
them transparency it may take a little
while so here I've actually converted to
bitmap just for the sake of expediency
got a few more minutes here so these are
so that was that top example I forgot to
show the ones down below here so here
you can see some additional examples we
have organs we've got muscles we've got
bones cartilage Tim shuttle Bauer's in
here I think yep Thames over here so Tim
was really useful and actually a Keiko
did a lot of the alignment so when we
had to course we had different sources
for the models then from the entities
and so we had to align these in Keiko
was very useful actually aligning these
two things so that we knew which models
went with which thing and then Tim
actually was very helpful in helping us
go through each of the tissue types and
in some cases overriding individual
organs so that they had colors that were
a little bit more illustrative and
obvious to people so we had to manually
color all these models ourselves because
originally it was just geometry that we
obtained so you can see the torso with
some of the organs in there and here's
an example where we have a you know clip
planes once again where we've kind of
shown the entire left upper limb and
we've kind of just cut away the muscles
but we didn't get rid of them entirely
we have two clipping planes in there and
on one side everything is their normal
solid color and on the other side that
kind of transparent backlit look so it
kind of does a wipe you could actually
animate this and actually I've got an
animation I'll show here in a few
minutes where you can see that and then
here's another case here where we're
showing some inner structure of the
brain even though the brain is not the
largest physical size structure the
model of it is actually quite large
because it's extremely dense there's a
lot of internal structure you don't
necessarily see if you just see the
outer model all those internal
structures have their own models and
they're all part of it so when you
download the brain it's actually pretty
decently sized even though it's not
physically the largest
okay so some future plans of things that
we're planning to do I kind of touched
on this a little bit earlier we're
planning to have some kind of name
directives you saw where I was creating
these custom lights and that can get
kind of messy it'd be nice if we had
kind of this idea of it's kind of like
plot themes but at the directive level
but we need some themes that are more
Anatomy targeted things like x-ray
things like that so we're trying to come
up with ways to have kind of string
named Anatomy forms for convenience that
would make it easy to do those kind of
styles there don't seem to be all that
many of kind of looked out there
different Anatomy visualizations they
all tend to use that kind of backlit
transparent look more than anything else
but we're trying to see if we can come
up with any others as well we are also
planning to support a plot theme x-ray
so I think Tim's I'm going to be working
with Tim in the near future to actually
come up with making plot things work
with this so I guess we'll have a
business forum for the brain we'll see
how that goes here's a few videos I'll
try playing these are notes going to try
these because the network should be good
so here you can see where I've rotated
the I've done the rotation transform
just over uh there's about 300 frames in
this animation so it's nice and smooth
[Music]
so used to windows not used on the Mac
everything's on the left there you go
back to my talk again there we go some
of these animations are ones that we
actually went to siggraph this year and
use these as part of the display there
so we've got a number of tissue types
and different styles and cutting planes
and stuff kind of revealing things that
are inside
[Music]
okay let's see here some of these I've
seen I'll come back to the others as
time allows I think we still got about
10 minutes left here so I jump to ones
that are so you saw screenshots of some
of these already so i'll go to someone's
here this is one we actually just
created the other day where we took all
the bones of the skull and apply to
scaling transform to all of them so i
tend to prefer looping animations the
ones that just kind of come to an end
just kind of stop and it's like the kind
of jarring but we threw it together very
quickly yesterday so this one here I
showed you a screenshot of this where I
just did one frame from it here you can
see where we kind of wipe away the
muscles but they're not actually
disappearing they're just changing their
styles so they're still there they're
just kind of transparent backlit
[Music]
ok
this actually was quite challenging
because I mentioned that the brain was
one of the denser structures that we
actually have and this became tricky for
the front end because by default the
rendering mode used by the front end has
a certain number of it's got a depth
specification and the number of polygons
we're looking through was so high that
it wasn't rendering quite right so I
actually had to add an option a front
end rendering option that's actually
you'll see it in the notebook the
notebook will be available that has the
has these but it allows you to actually
go through more polygons here to see all
that internal structure without
rendering artifacts so it's kind of a
hindbrain and all the the inner
structure there I'm sorry the midbrain
not the hindbrain the midbrain and some
of the surrounding structures around the
midbrain brainstem and some of these
take a long time with all the polygons
this took hours this was something I
kicked off at night kind of went to bed
and woke up the next day and kind of
continued to monitor it so it took hours
that was like six hundred frames and
that animation so it took a while to get
at that smooth transparency and
everything
so we're kind of more than halfway
through the conference now so there
aren't a whole lot of visualization
talks that are left but there are at
least a couple that might be if you're
interested in this you might be
interested in going to I'll mention the
custom entities talk that's actually
coming up on Friday at ten o'clock it's
not directly related to this but we are
making use of the anatomy entities here
and there's a lot of other entities and
you may want to expand onto your own
entities you may want to add your own
and Tony's giving a talk and how you can
actually create your own entity stores
and kind of expand entity values so that
you can create your own data sets so not
just use the ones that we provide to
create your own and then also youth sue
is actually going to be giving a talk on
Friday later in the afternoon for 24 30
on 3d graphics in general and I'm sure
he'll probably mention the clip planes
which I mentioned here and any other
improvements in the front end that have
happened for a graphics 3d language
there as well I've got a few links here
at the bottom it's mainly for
documentation but we've actually got
some you know knowledge base expansion
see there some of the anatomy models
were used there and we've refer to this
guy's into t-man you can't really see it
here probably because it's not zoomed in
enough but these bands that run across
here the scanner textured with a whole
bunch of entities so you can actually
see entities wrapped around him Michael
Michael trot created that one so we've
got a number of other examples some of
which are Anatomy but you can see some
of the other datasets we've made use of
and then also a number of other new
visualization domains not just Anatomy
but uh lots of others so he's probably
if you've been to any of the other
visualization talks that have already
happened you've probably seen some of
these used as examples lots of word
clouds cellular automata there's the
anatomy stuff so that's basically I've
got any questions yeah this stuff time I
assume right yep okay yep any questions
well caicos actually been to the company
that actually provided the models we
didn't create these models in-house
these are actually provided by company
called body parts 3d and they're based
in Japan they're kind of an idealized
person right and they're not made from
one person these are not something that
are made from a cat-scan they're not
volumetric models that are all surface
models but they're kind of a hodgepodge
of multiple peoples are correct and then
he the guy who puts these together
manually tweaks these things so that
they actually all fit together so it's
kind of an idealized person we actually
did try a first data set that was
actually I think visible human or
something like that and that was
volumetric where a guy had donated his
body to science and when he died they
throws him and then sliced him in one
millimeter slices from head to toe and
then they scanned each slice and then
tagged every pixel as to what structure
it corresponded to and we actually tried
building the surface models from that
volumetric data and it kind of worked
but number one it really looked like a
guy had been left out on a slab a little
too long it wasn't real attractive to
look at he was not a perfect individual
he was missing some parts and Stevens
kind of squeamish actually didn't really
like looking at them and the data sets
were actually quite huge the volumetric
data was a bit much it was very cool but
these models are just surface models and
they're already large to deal with if we
had push forward with that it would have
been really hard for I think a lot of
machines to do the entire thing as
volumetric models so but there are more
models coming there's just one size at
some point we hope to have the female
but right now I don't think they even
have the female is that correct yeah
they don't the company that we get these
models from doesn't yet have a female
but we're hoping to eventually add those
as well to have 3d models for that and I
actually was just told that she heard
from them yesterday they have some
additional muscles things like that some
of the smaller structures are still
missing we don't have everything yet so
like facial muscles there's a lot of
facial muscles we don't have yet and
some of the smaller nerves veins things
like that so as he has time he provides
them and we incorporate the men so we're
hoping to expand those yeah
it would be cool I wouldn't say there's
currently plans to do it maybe maybe
yeah well we have an example of that
we've had one since that actually
anatomy data came out Michael truck came
up with this example where he actually
took the transcending colon just the top
part of the colon here the horizontal
part and he actually used the ND
eigenvalues to actually find the
oscillation modes of the transcendence
colon so we have a vibrating colon in
our documentation examples there in
there the models are in there and you
can do any computations you could do on
any other model just like you could with
anything else I can't speak to exactly
how detailed the little brachii and
everything are the tiniest structures
but you definitely see them if you if
you plot the trachea and you plot the
lungs and stuff you'll see a lot of that
in there I can't speak to the exact
detail and you know the tiniest
structures in there but it looks they're
actually pretty decently sized so i'm
guessing the number of the amount of
detail and there's pretty high we've
actually been in communication with a
guy that's actually doing
electromagnetic he actually does study
on electromagnetic like tissue
penetration for like like if you're if
you're going to model how deep a cat
scan or something like that would go
into a particular type of tissue he
actually models that and we're actually
probably going to be in talks with him
to try to incorporate some of that
information so that we have more
physical information i should say that
when i showed that model of the moving
jaw that's easy because the bones are
rigid structures what we don't have is
any mechanical information that rapping
talk up here so we don't have any
mechanical information about muscles how
they bend stretch things like that so if
you tried to make a moving model of that
they're just going to separate if you
tried to move them you can rotate them
but they're going to act like a rigid
structure so it's easier to create
animations of bones moving things like
but not necessary with the muscles that
requires a lot more data we just the
models themselves don't have that
information so they're not allowed the
stretch so all right I can take any
additional questions outside in the
hallway or downstairs but I want to wrap
up so that the next speaker come out
here thank you
[Applause]